un tribunal del este de ucrania
controlado por rusia ha condenado a
muerte a dos británicos y a un ciudadano
marroquí tras un proceso de tres días de
duración fueron capturados mientras
luchaban para el ejército ucraniano en
mariupol
esperaba que la sentencia fuera mucho
más justa y teniendo en cuenta que ayude
a la investigación y también porque me
entregué a la república popular de
donets los dos británicos se entregaron
a las fuerzas prorrusas en la ciudad
portuaria de mariupol en abril mientras
que el ciudadano marroquí se rindió en
la ciudad oriental de bolt no baja en
marzo cada uno de ellos se declaró
culpable en diferentes tribunales de la
república popular de danielle los
separatistas les acusan de ser
mercenarios a pesar de que afirman haber
luchado junto a los militares ucranianos
moscú ha argumentado que los
considerados mercenarios extranjeros que
luchan por ucrania no son combatientes
regulares y por lo tanto no tienen
derecho a las protecciones concedidas a
los prisioneros de guerra una afirmación
muy discutida por los funcionarios
ucranianos y británicos
existentes
se trata de dos ciudadanos británicos y
han estado sirviendo en las fuerzas
armadas ucranianas mucho antes de la
invasión ilegal de ucrania por el
régimen de putin fueron capturados por
las fuerzas armadas rusas cerca de
mariupol y deben ser tratados de acuerdo
con la convención qué es el derecho
internacional como prisioneros de guerra
snell
un funcionario pro ruso de tony a es que
dijo que se les impuso la pena de muerte
como una forma excepcional de justicia
son los primeros combatientes
extranjeros condenados por los
separatistas ucranianos apoyados por
rusia y tienen un mes para apelar la
sentencia